they tweets by President Trump sign in
today I'll sign an executive order that
directs the federal government to
replace outdated degree based hiring
with skill based hiring this is scary
stuff for colleges and universities but
anyway right then he says Friday during
a meeting with American workforce policy
advisory board the federal government
will no longer be narrowly focused on
where you went to school but the skills
and the talents that you bring to the
job this is what we just said I pull up
what Elon Musk said recently what they
do with Tesla if you want to bring up
that article that we have up there check
this out
Elon Musk said a college degree isn't
required for Java Tesla Apple Google
Netflix don't require employees to have
a four-year degree either however while
all this stuff is going on while all
this stuff is going on guess what
Harvard says today Harvard says today
for 2020 2021 class they're doing 100%
online Harvard Harvard is the pinnacle
you know 40 billion dollar endowment 60
whatever the amount is they got a lot of
money in their endowment they announced
that we're doing it all online however
here's the kicker
the $49,000 tuition you still have to
pay hundred percent of it even though
it's all online so having said that what
are your thoughts about Trump and what
harbor is doing right now I don't think
people realize this is a game changer I
mean this is what we've been saying all
along for a long time we've said that
we're gonna move away from the pay per
degree and who has more degrees than a
thermometer but doesn't know how to do
it like okay so degrees I've got one
with them yeah I've got one semester of
college under my belt I've been
president of two very very successful
companies had a nice exit on one of the
companies and I've got what a semester
yet I've got a huge brand Pat you're
you've you've been how much school no
for your no to your new home yeah you're
worth so much money Saddam Hussein is
jealous the Iraqis are furious
for your snide right this time okay but
think just just think about here at
value teaming we've got some of the best
video editors we've got some of the best
producers we've got some of the best
graphic designers how many of them have
four-year degree you got a college
degree Paul you got a four-year you do
sam four-year you got to double degrees
whatever we don't hiring this but watch
are you you got a degree guy degree no
the agreement is loudest guy in the
office okay but but maybe that Sams Sams
degrees not even in video I think it's
in like accounting or okay so it's
becoming less of a life sling swing yeah
yeah but but Pat win-win when we hire
guys at the agency that we're about to
announce here in the next couple of
weeks we don't hire guys that have
four-year degrees to run ads at these
agencies because they're graduating with
degrees in my space okay and that's what
there's this frustration especially in
the tech industry with people that are
graduating with degrees in my space but
then Facebook snapchat like they're so
far behind times we don't got four-year
degrees we got four year Stein's
slightly funny or know how to find a one
from a comedian you go ahead what do you
think about this stuff skills pay the
bills degrees base fees you know it's
like so your team Trump on this you're
with them if you want to label me team
Trump on this on this I think more than
anything people are coming but realize
your skills pay the bills degrees yours
much anymore
here's here's why I think that this is
good that I'm gonna get your your take
on a Pat think about how many people are
no longer gonna feel like they have to
be tied to a degree therefore tied to
student debt think about how many people
this is gonna liberate because we're
gonna take the handcuffs off of the
these these kids and they're not gonna
be handcuffed with flippin 200 300
thousand dollars worth of student debt
for the beginning of their professional
career but what's the disclaimer here
though
tell us you still need to be educated
you can't just watch it from high school
and I'm go that's what he's saying
about Josh but anyone who's just
listening and just basically saying I
don't need to agree I'll do whatever I
want
you still got to read you guys still got
to put in the work but you no longer
needs a you know look burden yourself
this student loan this is coming from a
guy myself I went to Glendale Community
College I had a English teacher named
Van Damme which a great last thing about
especially at that time in 1977 Van
Dam's a great lesson can you imagine go
to club and he said what's your name
girl you know she says Mary what's your
name van all right can you imagine that
right with the kick Ryan he's come on
so me and Cogan used to go to take Van
Dam and eventually one day I tell
coconuts of coke and you're not gonna
find me this class in my more doubt of
my mind I would sit out then it would
play space with my buddy arm one okay
now our moan ends up you know he runs
one of the best restaurants in LA called
Raffi's place shout out to Raffi's place
to everybody and Glenda who goes to
Raffi's place and he does what he does
now it's Mike now he goes and gets his
degree later on but he runs his business
now Steve on another hand is one of our
friends him and his friend Alfred very
good friends of our Steve was a Michael
Jordan our high school he was a
transportation company about though he
says he's watched every episode and he
sent a video to me that I'm gonna play
for people to watch Steve if you're
watching this shout out to Steve and
awful for saying this is the Michael
Jordan of your high school may be better
than a Michael John at our house because
every record in our high school Wow
people would drive just to watch this
guy play but he was 510 and 9th grade he
was 510 and he's senior yeah if I would
if I would have given in my height he
would have been in the officer says he's
the Michael Jordan of ping pong at pH P
well here's here's Michael Jonah pa pa
tree ping pong at the officer so so but
going back to it Steve runs a business
with off what they do around 300 million
dollars per year okay we run a nice
sized business over here with what we do
our 15,000 agents right I see all of
these stories with degrees guy dropped
out of college I got a couple things and
an I left went into business this right
here with this executive order this is
scary for every single University here's
why when I read today's article about
what Harvard announced by though if you
chandus pressed a thumbs up if you're
liking this and share this so we can get
to the 2000 number and we'll be
announcing after the eighth episode if
we're going to go do this live or not
but so far we're having a good time so
uh uh again press the thumbs up and
comment below and share this so we can
get more of our friends on this year now
watch what happens here I posted
something on Facebook today with what
Harvard just announced and here's what I
said I said why doesn't Harvard just
come out and announce to everybody that
they're a business you're not a
university stop claiming your university
you ain't no University your priorities
not education your priority is endowment
why do you need to get me to pay forty
nine thousand dollars a year to your
school why you couldn't do forty nine
thousand or twenty nine thousand you can
do it at twenty eight thousand why are
you doing at a forty nine thousand are
you not saving a lot of money yourself
what kind of an organization are you and
you're still sitting on guy find out how
much money Harvard has on their
endowment
what is it sixty billion if you can pull
it up right here universities with
biggest endowments okay endowment yeah
there you go w perfect typing well forty
one universities don't type in well
endowed we have a Christian Joshua's
family's not gonna watch the podcast
Harvard has 41 billion dollars in
endowment do you know what that is Chi
Chi how many students does Harvard have
every year that they go to Harvard is at
six thousand I think the number is six
thousand I'm gonna do basic math here
for you okay I'm gonna do basic math
here for you they got 22,000 students
per year all of them this one there's
roughly sixty seven hundred students who
attend Harvard College but 22,000 per
euro okay so let's take forty billion
dollars forty billion dollars Harvard
forty billion in endowment okay that's
if we were to divide this by what forty
nine thousand dollars if we divided it
by forty nine thousand dollars Harvard
has eight hundred and sixteen thousand
students they can pay this for if we
divided that by twenty two thousand
students per year
Harvard can pay free tuition for every
single one of their students for 37
years you mean to tell me mr. Harvard
all the professors that are at Harvard
all the incredible professors that would
they care about is what social
all the social awareness all the good
things they want to do you couldn't say
if you if you made it to Harvard for the
next six months tuition free you
couldn't do it you couldn't say Harbor
we're gonna do 50% no you got to take
forty nine thousand dollars Harvard just
send the tweet out already and say we
are for profit we are not for pertinent
profit we are for profit we are a
business we're not a university and if
you did that you know what I would say
cool I don't have a prom scent of my
kids to accompany to learn how to do
things but you're definitely not a
university your business so this
executive order right here
if I made Dean out of big University I'm
shivering right now saying this could
completely change our business model do
you do you think that Trump's doing this
because he knows that higher education
as we showed Adam just a few weeks ago
that higher education is run by the
liberal left and so he sees it as an
opportunity to basically make going to
college with the exception of if you're
going to medical school or blah blah
blah stem stem ecology no question about
it do you think he's trying to make
college irrelevant because he knows it's
controlled by the Liberals uh it could
be it could potentially be that
direction but I don't think it's fully
that direction I just think for him he's
about skill over you know over but there
could be potentially somewhere in the
political side as well because again
you're sending your kids to school for
four years to realize how bad rich
people are on how bad capitalism is
[Music]
you